le coc vide en son temps l'apparition de
la variole du singe laisse place à de
multiples fausses d'information vous
allez déconstruire heureusement oui
ainsi le risque de transmission de ce
virus est encore assez faible celui de
propagation d un fox en revanche
risquent d'être élevés ce virus on
rappelle un qui n'est pas nouveau qui se
propage plutôt légèrement jusqu'ici une
centaine de cahors des foyers est
traditionnel depuis le 20 mai depuis
quatre jours donc des publications
twitter et facebook partage cette image
à regarder un calendrier que l'on voit
ici et vous noterez que le 15 mai 2022
donc il y à moins d'une semaine il
aurait une attaque plus précisément une
propagation de la variole du singe et
c'est à peu près à ce moment là qu'on a
commencé à parler de ces cas de variole
du singe on notera aussi ce mot brignac
on y reviendra tout à l'heure alors pour
ses comptes c'est sûr il ya une
corrélation entre cette simulation et
les infections récentes il vient d'où ce
calendrier est bien il vient de ce
rapport publié le 23 novembre 2021 enti
haye pour nucléaire frites initiative le
but de l'organisation de cette ong c'est
de prévenir les attaques liées à des
armes de destruction massive comme l'
arme biologique par exemple et ce
calendrier on ne retrouva la page 11 2
se disent très exactement de ce rapport
alors que nous apprend le rapport
d'abord que l'omg a effectivement bien
organisé un exercice de simulation
quand en mars 2021 pourquoi pour voir
les conséquences qu'aurait une pandémie
appliquant une souche inhabituelle du
virus de la variole du singe une
pandémie fictives dont dans la nation
tout aussi affectif c'est écrit ici de
brignoles vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
et surtout et c'est ça quand même son
importance et préciser ici le tout
conduit virtuellement entièrement
virtuelle parce que ce sont dix neuf
participants par visioconférence qui ont
réagi en trois temps trois périodes ce
sont elles que l'on retrouve dans le
calendrier en question qui est devenue
virale et cet exercice il est même
ponctué de faux
de faux séquence deux journaux télévisés
alors quant au calendrier justement la
date du 15 mai 2022 c'est un pur hasard
une pure coïncidence c'est ce qu'a
expliqué la vice présidente de l'ot
angie également co organisatrice de
l'événement arthur bahamas des
observateurs de france 24 elle revient
aussi sur le but de cette simulation
attirer l'attention des dirigeants pour
améliorer les capacités internationales
de prévention et de réponse
indépendamment du coffee 19 on écoute
alors ça pas très rassurant mais qui a
au moins le mérite d'être clair et puis
vous vouliez revenir anthony sur une
info qu' ce dont vous nous aviez parlé
sur ce plateau lié dix jours moi c'était
même avec voilà en deux mots après la
mort de la journaliste américano
palestiniennes chéri nabua clé un compte
twitter s'était fait passer pour son
frère c'était se compte en question il
avait ainsi gagné des milliers d'abonnés
en quelques jours je vous renvoie à
lenquête d'alexandre capron pour savoir
comment ils avaient passé au peigne fin
elle les traces numériques a notamment
via ce twitter heidi ce numéro unique
lorsque l'on créé un compte twitter il
avait découvert en fait quand quatre
jours en quatre mois pardon cet
usurpateur avait changé à plusieurs
reprises d'identité surf en chaque fois
sur l'actualité et gagnant donc des
followers et bien figurez-vous qu'il a
remis le couvert à la lumière de ce qui
s'est passé avec le joueur idrissa gueye
le joueur du psg qui ne s'était pas
associée à la journée contre mondiale
contre l'homophobie ce qui allait lui
avait valu des critiques on s'en
souvient refusé de porter le maillot est
effectivement alors le faux frère de la
journaliste est donc devenu le faux
joueurs du psg il en effet ce même
twitter à 10,1 ce numéro d'identité
twitter en quelque sorte des
supercheries à répétition qui lui ont
fait gagner plus de tenez vous bien
45000 follower en un mois seulement quel
but vendre peut-être se comptent bien
fournie sous le disais c'est possible
quelques centaines d'euros peut-être
ce possible en tout cas ce ne sera pas
pour tout de suite puisque après avoir
tenté de changer de nom idriss ghana est
devenu idriss ghana 0 peut-être pour
éviter l'interdiction et bien vous le
voyez ce compte a été suspendu tout est
bien qui finit bien donc mais des
comptes comme ça un tweeter en regorge
il joue souvent sur l'émotion des
utilisateurs d actualité que l'on évoque
et puis évidemment la crédulité des
utilisateurs des utilisateurs prudence
donc on le dira jamais assez précieux
conseils